ever since amazon conquered the online
book market people have been forecasting
the death of the local bookstore but
that long time feature of main street
america refuses to disappear in fact one
shop in downtown los angeles is
harnessing digital media to win global
fame cbs sunday morning correspondent
lee cowan takes us to the store that
calls itself the last bookstore
it all starts at the steps
the promise of westerns and thrillers
and mystery lure you up to a mythical
magical place
[Music]
you almost want to get lost in this
literary labyrinth here books fly
time stops gravity is suspended
everywhere you look books are celebrated
and where there aren't books
there's art everything from imagined
space age gadgets
to a woolly mammoth gazing down on the
mammoth collection of books below when
you see it in person it's a lot better
than in video it's like vintage very
eclectic it's unique
if you've never heard of the last
bookstore in downtown los angeles
don't be the last to visit it's a
cavernous place where old media and
social media collide sort of like the
big bang
only quieter
hashtag hungry instagrammers eat up
photo ops like catnip
while more traditional bookworms lounge
on couches
lost in the universe at their fingertips
a lot of people just come in off the
street and they don't even know what's
happening you know
and so they're just like what is this
what you know what's going on here is
amazing more than
being visually stimulating there's also
an ambiance here that you can't deny oh
yeah owners josh and jenna spencer have
been told that the last bookstore
is one of the most instagrammed in the
world
they're fully aware of the irony but the
digital age often credited with killing
books is here
keeping them alive but that wasn't your
intent though to make it instagramable
right
it was actually everyone was talking
about bookstores being passe and nobody
was buying books anymore and so i
thought well i've got to do something to
get
people's attention you know so i was
like well i'm just going to make
something that looks really really cool
and that people are going to want to
take pictures of and then they're going
to spread the word for us and
and so they did
beyond its photogenic properties the
last bookstore is a reminder that books
are meant to be tangible turning a page
instead of swiping one
matters to a lot of folks just
reconnecting myself to the past just by
holding these books is golden
paul gardner is a visiting librarian a
lot of ways it's sort of like a
pilgrimage yes a lot of these books are
old friends of mines that i haven't seen
in
forever the last bookstore's warehouses
are a rabbit warrant of millions and
millions of donated books stacked floor
to ceiling easy peasy and josh and his
team
sort through every single one so that's
kind of what we do all day is just dig
for treasure
growing up in hawaii josh never imagined
he'd one day open a bookstore although
there were some early hints i mean i've
always been a reader i mean my mom likes
to tell the story that i you know at
five years old my friends wanted me to
go outside and play and i had to tell
them no i'm reading the dictionary i
can't come out right now
so
but life can turn a page for you
whether you want it to or not i was 21
and i was riding a moped and just
got in a terrible accident ended up
being paralyzed from the waist down
that was clearly a new chapter in his
life which oddly
circled right back to the beginning
prior to that accident i was very
physical i'd gotten away from my first
level of reading i was just
more into playing volleyball and surfing
and lifting weights and things like that
so the accident
turned out to be a good thing in a way
and that it thrusts me back into the
world of books because i was like well
now i've got to figure out some other
way to be you know he started selling
cookbooks on ebay then he had a small
store and then
he found this old bank the beautiful
relic
just like books he thought
i just sat in here for a few hours just
kind of imagining what it could be the
wheels were turning
they're still turning what was the
bank's vault is now home to the horror
and true crime section how fitting for
years i've wanted to find like an
old-fashioned like electric chair and
put it here in the center
have like a prop you know but i've never
been able to find an electric chair for
sale so
you may do with other oddities like a
tunnel made of more than a thousand old
volumes that his dad helped him build
just how it stands is a secret
that many have tried to uncover
once in a while somebody will
manage to pry a book out of the tunnel
and steal it seriously we have to figure
out how to replace it yeah
thieves aside the book business is
apparently booming he and jenna have
opened a second store lost books where
you enter through a twinkling jungle and
these are all real plants these are all
real plants 365 real plants yeah it's
all growing yes and so the shape of the
tunnel changes
as the months move on there's tropical
fish and the ceiling is covered with
moss and you can buy just about anything
that's growing
right along with the books so do people
buy more books or more plants that is
the question
it's so new they really don't know it's
a risky venture just like the last
bookstore was more than a decade ago
it didn't matter if i lost everything
trying to do it it was important to me
and i couldn't imagine anything else
that i could personally do that was more
important
he sees books as the keeper of human
knowledge our history our achievements
our dreams his too
he could have given up after his
accident but books helped bring him back
to a place of purpose and passion
for which all readers
should be thankful
that's the key to life in a lot of ways
is difficulties obstacles challenges
you know that's the secret drawer that
you have to go through to really get to
the real good stuff of life
for cbs mornings i'm lee cowan in the
not so last bookstore after all
such a great piece i've always felt like
bookstores are candy shops for adults
yeah and there's nothing sweeter than a
good read that is true a book will
change your life and so will a bookstore
that's right